hi everyone my name is Thomas and along
with my colleague vivec we will be
covering webassembly and how it's
enabling a new paradigm of web
development
so let's start off by covering what
webassembly actually is and why you
would use it
well webassembly is a low-level binary
format for the web that is compiled from
other languages to offer maximized
performance and is meant to augment the
places where JavaScript isn't sufficient
so why use webassembly well there are
three main advantages first it offers
more reliable and maximized performance
second it enables great portability
since you can compile from other
languages enabling you to share your
code across deployments
lastly it offers greater flexibility for
developers who can now write for the web
in languages other than JavaScript
perhaps best of all it is now shipping
fully in every major browser so you can
reliably reach all of your users
in this talk we want to go over four
languages to show how they're coming to
the web and how you can get started
yourself
we're focusing on these four languages
in this talk but it's worth noting that
there are a ton of other languages that
are also adding support for webassembly
so let's dig in and start off with C
plus
one of the earliest areas where
webassembly transformed the web was by
enabling large applications such as
AutoCAD figma and most recently
photoshop on the web
these are performance demanding
applications with large code bases often
ported from other platforms AutoCAD
brought their code base which was
started over 40 years ago before the
first ever browser and now parts of that
original code base are directly
accessible with a simple link
figma made a big bet on webassembly from
the start and wrote their engine in C
plus for maximized performance
Photoshop has brought their complex
application to the web enabling easy
sharing across platforms with commenting
and editing
they'll also soon be using webml for
optimized machine learning operations
which you can hear more about in the
what's new with webml talk here at i o
in the last year we've continued to see
more of these incredible Advanced apps
leveraging wasm to come to the web
Snapchat wanted to expand Their audience
while using a single code base to hit
all of their platforms
they decided that C plus plus would give
them the performance and portability
that they needed
by leveraging webassembly they can
deliver their entire application
directly in the browser across all
operating systems
snap is also investing in bringing their
amazing camera kit to the web through
webassembly which you can try yourself
right at web.snapchat.com
here they're again reusing their C plus
implementation that is shared across
platforms they're using m-scripted
including its M bind binding systems and
opengl to webgl conversion
they're also using tensorflow.js for ML
inference web workers for off-screen
rendering and performance optimizations
using the Chrome profiling tool
WordPress has done something rather
incredible and actually managed to get
the WordPress server environment built
to run directly in the browser this
relies on compiling the PHP interpreter
itself and SQL Lite to webassembly
with this users can try out WordPress
directly in the browser with zero setup
this is amazingly impactful for getting
started enabling interactive tutorials
and eventually supporting easy
publishing of backends
by running on wasm they can now also
deploy to non-browser environments
including node.js or other wasm server
environments
you can read tons of interesting details
in this deep dive blog post
all of these examples are powered by the
M script and Tool chain M scripting will
help compile your C plus code but also
helps port code built against posix apis
and will even translate opengl calls to
webgl
to get started go to instagram.org
we've also made really substantial
improvements in enabling webassembly
debugging with this support you can now
see your C plus code in devtools set
breakpoints step through your code and
even see runtime values of variables
visit this link to see how now you might
be thinking to yourself I'm not writing
C plus plus or building a large
cross-platform application I'm doing web
development well this is where
webassembly libraries are going to
change your life
these libraries include things like
opencv for image analysis tensorflow.js
for ML skia for graphics sqlite for
database F of MPEG for video
manipulation and so so much more you can
dig into these examples at this URL
these examples all expose JavaScript
apis and you might not even know that
they're powered by webassembly under the
hood except for how amazingly performant
they are
so let's take the incredible web app for
telegram as an example
telegram is a traditional web
application with the majority of
functionality built in JavaScript but
there were a few areas where they needed
some additional functionality that they
found in webassembly
specifically they use the r Lottie
renderer for animated stickers Opus
recorder for voice recording and
decoding fast text web for language
detection and webp hero for Dot webp
support in safari
and indeed when looking at npm there
were 1500 packages with webassembly
if you're a library author in really any
language and you're interested in
bringing your library to the web now is
your moment if you'd like to connect
directly with us provide feedback on
your experience or even get featured on
web.dev you can visit this link
so now that we've covered C plus plus
let me jump into Swift
it's been possible to compile Swift to
webassembly for a while but it's only
recently that the tool chain and
ecosystem have matured to a point where
this is truly shippable in production
one such application that is shipping
Swift on webassembly in production and
coming to the web is good notes they had
invested a decade of work in creating
the most incredible iOS application full
of cool features with a 4.8 star rating
they decided it was time to spread their
application to non-ios users and rather
than having to do an incredibly
expensive rewrite that would also have
to be separately maintained they decided
to reuse their Swift Investments through
webassembly
this means their decade of work can be
reused while also minimizing maintenance
costs
when we talked to them one of my
favorite things they said was quote
every day our iOS developers contribute
something new to our Swift Code base and
our web app benefits from that
in terms of their Tech stack they're
utilizing Swift on webassembly react as
their UI framework and pwa for
installability
they have a great Tech talk with lots
more details at this link
they do their surrounding UI in react
and have a central canvas connected to
the Swift engine this is the same
pattern that we saw with our previous
partners
as an example when a user clicks
something like add page it calls from
The Click Handler in react into the
Swift Code base to add the page and then
make it ready for input
the tool chain they use is called Swift
wasm and you can get started with that
on swiftwasm.org
the tool chain includes JavaScript kit
which enables your Swift code to
interact with JavaScript through
bindings and translating types and
objects
it also offers carton which provides a
swift alternative to something like
webpack it lets you easily bundle and
deploy your app while also shipping your
code to other platforms
as with anything there are some
limitations that developers should be
aware of
I want to be clear that this isn't a
magic button that will make your Swift
app run directly on the web and while
it's dramatically faster than a rewrite
it's not zero effort Swift Code and
Swift UI should work well but things
like storage UI kit networking and files
need to utilize web alternatives
still if you're a swift developer who
has been hoping to expand your
addressable Market this is your moment
so now I want to take a step back from
any specific language and update you a
bit on the progress of the webassembly
standard itself
in the past we've discussed how
webassembly threads and simdi can offer
a 10x or more Improvement for
performance sensitive workloads for an
overview of how powerful these features
can be and how to get started check out
this video from chrome devsell and we're
continuing to expand with even more
Cindy instructions to further maximize
performance
the tail call proposal is a critical
optimization for functional programming
languages and enables better support for
C plus programs using Code routines the
memory 64 proposal gives applications
the ability to reference more than four
gigs of memory and making it easier to
port code that assumes a 64-bit
architecture
lastly the JavaScript promise
integration API lets synchronous code
access asynchronous apis without
substantial code size or performance
overhead this is a big deal if you're
trying to make code that assumes the
synchronous environment work with the
web
now to continue our language Journey I'm
going to turn it over to my colleague
vivec
[Music]
thanks Thomas you may remember at last
year's Google I O we previewed our plan
to bring new languages like Java kotlin
and dart to the web
over the past year the webassembly
community has been busy making this
happen so let's talk a bit about what we
built and what this new technology makes
possible for developers across the web
and Native mobile platforms
as Thomas mentioned webassembly has
taken off among developers using C and C
plus as well as a growing Community
around rust in these languages
developers are responsible for in a
sense cleaning up after themselves
freeing objects from memory after an
application is done using them this
class of languages was the primary focus
of the early web assembly standard what
we call webassembly MVP in part because
these were the languages many large
desktop applications were written in and
also because they had somewhat simpler
requirements When developing the
webassembly standard
another class of languages manages
memory on behalf of the developer the
language's own runtime automatically
finds and frees memory that the app is
no longer using
this class of languages is really
interesting if you're building web or
mobile apps because JavaScript is the
language in which the web's own apis are
specified and standardized and kotlin
and dart are increasingly popular among
developers building cross-platform
native mobile apps
so we wanted to figure out what would it
take to extend the web platform to
Applications written in these languages
in a performant way
so let's walk through how we do that
when a web app starts in the browser
it's given a context for its JavaScript
code and some heat memory
JavaScript memory is garbage collected
so there's a garbage collector provided
by the browser behind the scenes
now when an app instantiates a
webassembly module it asks for and is
allocated a region of linear memory for
its own use
if the developer is using a language
like C or C plus plus then the
webassembly module uses some of this
memory for a dynamic Heap and a
developer would handle freeing objects
on that Heap after they're used
on the other hand if the developer
wanted to use a managed memory language
then the webassembly module will need to
include that language as garbage
collector code to manage the Heap and
automatically free up unused memory
there were two main problems with this
approach
the first is obviously bloat the
webassembly module has to ship and
instantiate that garbage collector every
time the app is loaded this increases
the module size and delays the
application startup despite the fact
that every standards compliant browser
out there already contains a garbage
collector for apps to use another form
of bloat comes from the need for
developers to have a kind of
Clairvoyance when deciding how much
memory to request for their module
to avoid crashes the typical thing to do
is to set a maximum memory size that is
just beyond the upper bound of your
anticipated memory needs
this puts more pressure on
implementations who have to manage the
app's JavaScript and webassembly memory
separately alongside the memory needed
by other apps and tabs that the user
might be using
the second problem is what I call the
split brain problem in this architecture
those two memories and their garbage
collectors know nothing about each other
this means developers need to be careful
to architect their applications to avoid
corruption when for example the
JavaScript garbage collector comes along
and frees up memory that's actually
still needed by the wasm side or vice
versa
all this adds up to more bookkeeping
that developers have to do themselves
which kind of breaks the whole reason to
use a managed memory language in the
first place but even if you put all of
your objects on one side on the
webassembly side you can't avoid dealing
with the JavaScript Heap and that's
because of web apis
web apis are specified to accept and
return JavaScript objects which
naturally live on the JavaScript Heap
and are collected by the JavaScript
garbage collector
in the original version of webassembly
this meant copying your data in both
directions between webassembly and
JavaScript anytime you wanted to call a
web API
Graphics apis like the Dom canvas webgl
and web GPU are especially impacted by
this since in some cases they need to be
called hundreds of times per frame or
thousands of times per second with very
strict latency requirements to avoid
user visible Jank
the net result is even after we built a
fast compilation Target for code many
Frameworks and applications ran the risk
of producing jankier experiences on the
web compared to what they would be able
to produce on Native mobile platforms
so how do we address this well the
webassembly community created a new
extension that in effect shares a joint
Heap between JavaScript and webassembly
GC modules
now your manage memory code can just
allocate modules on this joint Heap and
when the browser's garbage collector
comes around JavaScript and webassembly
GC objects are garbage collected
together
this means no more bloat your
webassembly module doesn't have to ship
its own full garbage collector
implementation with your app and your
webassembly app can more easily grow or
Shrink its memory consumption as needed
just like a Javascript app can
some browsers including Chrome will even
return unused webassembly memory from
this shared Heap to the operating system
whenever possible helping ensure all
apps running on the user's device remain
efficient and responsive the web API
story improves as well webassembly GC
modules create objects in the same Heap
where the JavaScript web apis will look
for them and return values are easily
passed back as well all without
excessive copying
so that's webassembly GC smaller
binaries for modern managed memory
languages faster interop with JavaScript
code and the javascript-based web apis
and a dynamically resizable memory
footprint that grows and shrinks to
provide your module with what it needs
with webassembly GC the web can finally
give a proper Welcome to our developer
Friends building flutter Android and
kotlin multi-platform apps let's look at
what webassembly GC means for you
early data shows that webassembly GC now
runs code compiled from these languages
in the browser up to two times faster
than compiling them to JavaScript
from a user's point of view this level
of performance is increasingly
indistinguishable from what they would
see on Native mobile platforms we're
talking about apps running at 120 frames
per second with single millisecond frame
update times
we can now imagine a world where
cross-platform Frameworks can build apps
for Native mobile platforms and the web
with no perceivable difference in
capabilities or performance
and the developer experience gets better
too previously developers would have to
build separate native Android and iOS
apps as well as a web app to reach the
broadest set of users
cross-platform Frameworks like kotlin
multi-platform mobile let developers
write their mobile apps business Logic
the part that manages user data and
implements your app's features in a
single code base that compiles to both
Android and iOS
while implementing their user interface
using platform native Frameworks and
widgets but extending this
cross-platform capability to the web ran
into some challenges
for a long time you couldn't really
compile mobile languages like kotlin to
the web
at best you could transpile it to
JavaScript and then run that JavaScript
in a browser
this approach produced apps on the web
that just weren't as fast and smooth for
users as they would be on Native mobile
platforms
now thanks to webassembly's new support
for managed memory languages
cross-platform apps can compile directly
to the native runtime of all three
platforms giving developers access to
the reach and instant startup of the web
and giving users a fast and smooth
experience wherever they find your app
the kotlin community also benefits from
UI Frameworks like compose which can
help developers share much of their UI
code as well across platforms again with
the performance level matching that of
native platforms
here's Sebastian from jetbrains to share
more about kotlin multi-platform and
compose
[Music]
thank you vivec
jet brains we think webassembly is a
promising technology and we want kotlin
developers to get all the benefits it
has to offer just recently we released
an experimental version of the
webassembly target for the kotlin
compiler we see a lot of potential use
cases in kotlin wasm suture from
building high performance web
applications running in the browser to
building Speedy serverless functions I
want to show you a concrete example of
one such thing that is part of the
potential future of kotlin wasm so here
you can see an application built using
jetpack compose the declarative and
modern UI framework created by Google
for Android you may have actually seen
this specific app before now at
jetbrains we're working on bringing
jetpack compose to multiple other
platforms beside Android like desktop
iOS and web in practice this means that
you can take any knowledge about the
apis of Jetpack compose that you might
have from developing for Android and use
it to Target other platforms the web
Target good for compose is built on top
of cotton Wesson it's still experimental
but let me show you what we can already
do with it here is the same application
you just saw on Android running in
Google Chrome it looks and behaves just
like we saw on Android before if we want
to get an idea of the current
performance of this app we can open the
FPS counter in Chrome's Dev tools and
watch some of these beautiful animations
we're also working on making it possible
for you to debug kotlin code right
inside your browser and inspect
variables and stack traces right in
Chrome's devtools using the build-in
support for Source Maps now let's move
back to IntelliJ IDEA and take a quick
look at the code of our app as you can
see the UI and business logic of the app
are all located in the common module
it's all code that is shared between the
different targets for the project but we
can also specify platform specific Logic
for the individual Targets in the
respect of sub-projects that way we
still get to use everything in terms of
platform specific apis okay so after
making a small change to our code we can
actually have a look at the result of
the changes and look at that they appear
right in the browser we hope this little
demo made you want to learn more about
this experimental technology we're
building a jetbrains if that's the case
follow the link and check out the
project sources for this demo yourself
thank you and take care
thanks Sebastian you can learn more
about kotlin running on the web with
webassembly at kotlinlang.org and we're
not just making Android apps
multi-platform with kotlin
multi-platform developers have been
using flutter for years to Target
Android iOS and the web and on the web
flutter developers have also had to
transpile to JavaScript to run in the
browser
but we're unlocking faster performance
for flutter web as well for the first
time this year compiling Dart code
directly to fast and efficient
webassembly code in the browser
you can read more about the exciting new
performance boost offered by flutterweb
at flutter.dev wasm on the open web your
app is just a click away from New users
who can Discover it and share it just as
easily as they share a web page with no
stores getting in the way and no Revenue
split affecting your profitability
the productivity of cross-platform
development the performance of native
mobile apps and the openness of the web
that's why we love webassembly on behalf
of Thomas myself the flutter team and
our friends at jetbrains thank you so
much for joining us we can't wait to see
what you'll build next
[Music]